thank you i would like to thank you
thank the organizers for the invitation
to speak here so i'm going to talk about
some joint work with uh frank cavone he
was a former phd student of mine and
then mission one from chinese academy of
sciences
i'm going to first start with some
basics about the global basis i know
most of you probably know this already
but just in case some
forget and also this also set up a
stage i want to try to do a parallel to
the to the new firm i'm going to talk
about
and i'm going to talk a little bit about
the complex issues and end
so i'm going to start with the in my
talker f4 can be any field okay so final
fields number fields etc or real number
of course when you do implementation
that could be easier so but in the talk
i'm mostly i'm going to focus
exclusively on just the theory okay
without a talk about anything about the
implementation issue
so i'm going to give a
polynomial
f uh m employment with n variable and
the defined idea that's all the
completions of f
so so the
uh for suppose you're giving any
monomial order uh
uh so and a subset g of i is called the
group basis
if
uh if if every colonial we have the ever
plummet in the ideal is reducible by g
okay i'm going to define the moment uh
that is oh actually that's make sense
that is there exists some problem in g
so that the leading monomial of t
divide the little monomial for f so this
has to be true for every polynomial in
the ideal then we say this is a growth
basis okay
some simple
example like we we knew right if f are
just little polynomials every single and
variable if you try to compute group
basis that's called simulation and the
growth base would be corresponding to
relational form or triangular system in
that case
if if i uh universe in one variable some
variable
then this group
actually corresponds to the gcd of the
polynomial
in general
this definition
for whatever order you're given the
growth basis basically
consists of all the minimum polynomial
of minimum of minimum whatever that
order
so the
what i'm going to talk about this works
for polynomial ideals and also works for
our module any arm module if you think
about the generator somewhere in there
uh
everything will be very similar and
we're going to just talk about the idea
okay
and of course word bases are very
important so probably everybody we know
i don't have to say anything about that
uh so let me just work quick okay so uh
give some uh uh examples of some
monomial waters uh so the important
things here is that this uh
has to be uh
well 82 monomial can compare and uh has
to be compatible with multiplication
that's important so if you use some
monomial smaller than another monomial
if times any monomial has to be smaller
still smaller okay that's compatible
with the multiplication
and then we're going to use a location
like a leading monomial leading
coefficient
those concepts like for example for a
simple example if you use uh
if you use a legs order
uh so we just think about x anything
evolving x is bigger than x y because x
involves z and then this formula needing
leading
leading monomial is just x little
coefficients 10 and this monomial if i
use a greater order use twitter to the
degree first then use the next order
then the leading well the highest has
highest degree well then
x first and then y so here's the
y it is
uh bigger than zero so this would be my
leading term i need a monomial teacher
so those are
uh
so the top reduction we're gonna we're
gonna uh we're gonna use that's how
we're gonna define that later on also
for for the homogeneous frame
uh so if we say the in in the difference
co well is reducible by g so the leading
monomial of g or dividing minimum of f
right that's the deflation there we used
in the group basis so actually they're
corresponding to a reduction this
reduction is to
is to reduce the big term to try to try
to cancel them so
if you do long division you try to
cancel as many terms as possible
and this is just reduce the biggest term
uh implementation you could also reduce
the middle whatever in the middle term
you can also do it but for the zero we
don't need that here
okay uh one important concept in boho
berger's ergosome is an s colonial so we
try to create a more polynomial to add
to
to the list
so for any two polynomial uh fg so we
created this x colonial uh basically you
don't have to memorize the formula just
a single bottom f and the g i try to
multiply by some monomial t1 and t2
so that the leading term they have the
same leading term okay i want to try to
try to find the minimum volume t1 and
minimum t2
so that the lead term cancel okay and
then they also you have to make up
coefficients so they're gonna also
coefficient cancel that's all okay so
that's how you create a s polynomial
uh
so for example here uh this one so you
just look at the two monomials just look
at the lcm
uh so so these times together they have
the same common term they cancel now
what's left
is the other other other terms
okay now one important criterion is that
uh so in the definition of growth basis
you have to check all polynomial in
ideal that's infinitely okay so you
cannot check any final time but this
criteria allow us to do it in final time
so so this says that if
if g is a subset and this is a generator
is ideal
then this g is the goal base 5 if and
only if for every pair in here you
create a s polynomial the s polynomial
they try to use g to reduce okay you can
always just keep keep reducing you can
always reduce zero for any pair of them
so
uh
then this is a you can you can prove
that the for edit format can always
reduce this finite middle steps can you
can reduce okay and also there's only a
fundamental pair so this is a finite
time argument you can determine finding
time and it's very easy to prove
so from this one you immediately have
this uh
workers arguments so just basically you
start with the list you just create x
polynomials just keep a list
and try to make sure all the reduced
zero often reduce zero if it does not
reduce zero you add to the list create a
create a more exponential they just keep
going okay so now then lots of uh
now the main things here is that uh see
you have a s polymer charge try to
reduce uh reduce by g well how can
that's the next step uh so this step
reduction okay if i have s uh polynomial
we we have many variables that step is
very expensive okay so
and also uh and also the this stuff for
x colonial is huge okay there are many
many millions of depending on if we have
started with reasonable system
polynomial there are a thousand million
of polymer you have to reduce okay so
this step is very slow i know and the
one question is that how do you how do
you detect s polynomial because most of
them will be reduced to zero the
question that can we can we somehow
detect it without doing reduction you
say okay this
must reduce zero we don't have to even
do reduction okay can we do that so
that's it
now in fact uh if burberg he actually
give two simple criteria this is one of
them the simpler one if you look at the
leading little monomial of qgi and other
two of them okay
again if the gcd the monomial are
related to prime
in this case it forms s problem and then
you can it can prove that they always
can be reduced to zero by g so in that
case then when you you don't have to
format x polynomial just uh
just the degree of that pair okay
so that saves time too
and there's another criteria i'm not
representing that one it's a little bit
more complicated so in fact so in other
paper and also more more
traversal paper they kind of try to make
collection between let's see actually we
have a pair reduced zero not
corresponding to sushi okay uh
in there that's kind of equivalent and
in the paper by the uh as i also point
out that if you work with this uh well
with all posts basically
uh okay i should i don't need that much
here basically all the possible
compilation of this polynomial you're
starting with
uh you can form a sylvester matrix of
the coefficients for the for the u then
you can do gossip simulation on the
matrix that's where you get a growth
basis okay but that's a very
inefficient case in general
and
and the base i think and then for zero
uh in 2002 introduced the signature try
to try to uh detect some of the useless
repair and
so uh
and also this one uh also speed up the
the process
uh
and in fact if we have started with a
regular sequence of colonial
uh then this algorithm actually doesn't
well
uh all the all the users pair will will
be detected okay
uh there are many after that paper right
so that paper is not a five favorite
it's not easy to understand and there
are some some issues in there and after
that many people try to
modify
and try to understand them try to
reformulate the direction in a way that
may make you work on this so it's
impossible for me to
actually talk about it uh in the detail
of those and also some people talk about
implementational issues
uh
so so what i want to do today is try to
set up the general kind of
framework so so that we can understand
all those algorithm easier okay so
uh
now let me start with this uh uh so in
general uh like i have a eight
polynomial system
now this h is all the couples
combination is zero that's the cg module
of of g
so we define another one so now we want
to actually compute the
group basis for the ideal and group
basis for the cdg module okay so so it
sounds like we're doing more but in fact
you'll see that uh because we're using
this
strategy will help us to detect the
useless pair so we're gonna actually
save time okay so so basically those are
module and ideal they are inter
related to each other
so we're going to work uh with uh with
the polomia as before so that's a
monomial we'll talk about and also we're
going to work her working with a module
uh m vector a vector of uh uh
er so this is a term here we're gonna
we're gonna use a lot so term of this
one would be a
will be a monomial times the position
okay just position you don't have to
write a vector just a position come from
each polynomial okay so that's a that's
the term when we talk about term in here
this means a term like this okay
uh
then
uh we're gonna you can talk about the
well for computer idea in r you have a
stereo motor or motor you start with
then this water can be extended to
this water in here
but the only uh there are many many
extensions giving example later on
but we have to be compatible okay so if
light compatible the rxm
presenter may not be may not terminate
in finding time okay
and this one actually is called uh this
order in here is called a signature
so we're going to just use location like
a kneading monomial of polymer leading
mole of vector here a vector just would
be like that one if i talk about the
vector so my bold phase is always a
vector okay
uh
so i'm not going to try to distinguish
like which order so r1 r2 in general
it's just a little more leading
coefficient in there
okay now
uh in for zero's paper
he introduced the the signature in the
following way
so that is for any polynomial v
so there's a combination of polynomial
g
then they define he defines the sequence
of v to be
the minimum basically minimal pair
minimal tuple such that this is actually
completion is equal to v so v has many
representation right representation and
my o such a representation you pick a u
you pick a u here where the leading
volume of u
is minimum this means i have a minimal
signature okay
so in the exam
we try to implement arts we try to try
to make sure this is satisfied and every
step so this is actually this is a
little bit harder to use
i'm going to relax that condition okay
instead of call the minimum one i'm just
introduce a introduced pair like a uv ed
pair uv this uv may not produce my u v
right produce my v i don't care this is
minimal a lot just anyone i just call
this a signature uh leading monument you
just call is called the signature of the
pair okay i'm not calling the signature
of the colonial instead the whole whole
pair signature okay just means that the
leading term of you
okay so that's why i so this is relaxed
you can use in practice so whatever pair
you're you're you're producing so this
this just means a little term for some
you
know that produce this this v
okay so i'm gonna so in the blue orgasm
we have top reduction okay here also we
have a uh have top reduction uh for zero
introduced so this is also uh
exactly almost exact same way as a
foreign defined
so now p wants to have two pairs in here
two pairs here we try to use let's say i
try to use p2 to d to reduce p1
okay so so the goal is here that we're
going to use the the polynomial try to
reduce the problem i try to reduce the
leading leading leading term of v okay
so we try to cancel this in term of
polynomial part
then we coded the record the the the
the u part okay that vector uh so now
the only condition is that where the
condition would of course need in terms
of this a little more has to divide into
one amount that's why divided also if v
v2 is non-zero we define this way divide
that to y then
it can cancel then you get to this part
this part you have to keep making sure
this leading the signature t times u2
right cannot get it bigger
if it's bigger then this is lighter you
cannot do
uh if this is a bigger than that one
then we don't do this reduction so
that's a lot so this is a we talk about
top reduction then we have to keep this
order of the signature of p1 the pair
never increase okay it could get smaller
but never increase okay that's the top
reduction
now what if v2 is zero or okay also uh
if uh well this is a leading term make
may become smaller if they're not the
same same as u1 then we say it's a
regular reduction okay we never
decreased regularly if uh if this uh
gets smaller let's get a smaller two
right then we say super super reduction
what if uh
v2 is smaller than v2 is zero so this is
zero this is actually corresponding to g
so we're going to define this to be
if this one reduces to p1 p1
if the leading monomer divides the
needle over u1 that's it so so then we
say it's top reducible in this case then
it's always super top reducible
so
we are under regular reduction then the
water never never gets smaller okay and
never get bigger it's just basically the
older the seedlings could remain the
same under regular reduction
so implementation we only
perform a regular regular
top reduction we have a super top
reduction we have that case this means
that the pair you throw them away you
don't have to continue to reduction
so
okay
now
i'm going to work here this is the
framework we're going to work working
this bigger module rm times r so we
start with any polynomial then we can
uh
define this module all the u right
another so u v is represented in term of
u okay that means all the
compatible u v in terms of the
polynomial so this is a sub module in
this in here then this module m is
denoted by this unit vector u e one just
indicative position so there's a unit
vector this is the generator of this
module
so basically we started with those
generators we try to create a
basis okay we're going to define this uh
strong group basis for m so we say that
a subset of g
of m is called the strong group basis
for m for this big module if every
pairing m every one here m is top
produced by some pairing g
you'll notice that this is a almost
exactly as the perplex deflection in the
polymer case so just say if anything
everything is top reducible
then it's a group basis but here i
uh we put this this part in here and the
reduction will keep the signature uh
the same okay basically that's the only
restriction here uh so we say a strong
group is over here
so
uh top reducible
now
if if you get a strong goal basis for
that big module
so if now you can read off suppose g
you're gonna grow uh supposedly verbose
for m now from here you can read alpha
group bases for for the for the ideal
and also for the cdg module immediately
you don't have to add a computation just
read off like for example
if you just collect all the v sum of v
are zero of course you can throw away
some maybe redundant you can throw away
so critically them then that's the group
base for the ideal the v part but the u
part
uh i'm going to click the only u part
where v i zero so if you lose a zero i
click this one if longer i don't click
here the zero part that's a
corresponding scissor g so this will
form a for a group basis for the 3g
module
so that kind of comes automatically
now
how do you how do you compute a stronger
basis so this would be very similar to
uh buffer berg's argument for s
polynomial so we're going to define j
pair
joint pairs so for uh for any two pair
we're going to create another pair the
corresponding s colonial uh
so it's like a so this v one v two
remember we try to connect create s
polynomial by do combination so the
polynomial part cancel
so cancel them you have this t one t two
c coefficient essentially right you have
those
number to cancel now here
we're gonna we're gonna do use the same
t1 t2 so the v part gonna cancel right
so so create the smallest finance
motorcycle problem monomial t1 t2 so the
leading monument cancel then look at
this part look at that part
well we have
we want to make sure the maximum leading
the signature here maximum one supposes
t depend on they could be equal okay it
could be the same monomial could be
equal
uh but we might amount of sure they
don't cancel if if they cancel if we do
this uh chromosomes pair if they cancel
then we don't define j pair so if they
don't cancel this means if you do that
one this the biggest term is still still
in there
then we say one of this this one with
whatever equal to the bigger one the
bigger one that's called the jpeg of
p1p2 so
notice that i don't define i don't call
this my jpl instead i call one one of
the
called as my chip here
so uh of course you could do the
reduction in and here
uh but in the serum you have to modify a
little bit so there's a lot much a big
difference but this one advantage is
that one you can store this very very
easily you just do the monomial ti and
store the pair the index pi you don't
have to slow the polynomial so so
this actually could be useful in
implementation and this t that's called
the
joint signature of p1p2 the biggest
whatever
signature that's the signature of
p1p2 so this is called a jpair
now this is the main serum the
criterium uh if we start with a uh okay
this is a this more virtual continuous
if i start with g
and subset of m and containers generate
should be capital you somehow change so
subset contains generators
uh
suppose this means that g will generate
were generated as a module
therefore eighth term
order on our r and the comparator motor
are m
the following are equivalent so you say
g is a strong basis for the big module
if and only if
every j pair of g is covered by g
okay so let's oh okay
uh so let's see let me try to explain
this uh
concept what do you mean by covered
uh cover so so if i say a pair is
covered by g this means that uh means
that i can find a pair in here so that i
can
i can t i times someone's signature i
can get the same thing by times t so
this pair times some t i get the same
signature
then this polymer part has to be
strictly smaller than
the polymer part of v
okay so this condition i only check
use a leading term okay this little term
so that was a cover p so
this condition has low reduction at all
okay
uh so so so
to check this
if we scroll based right so
we don't have to any reduction so every
step
okay so that gives us the criteria okay
so without the reduction if we have g
pair it's covered then just wait i
detect them zero way immediately so this
this uh this
uh criteria will uh
uh okay so okay maybe some comments i'm
gonna skip them uh
okay let's see i want to i want to say
something on the
okay well okay this is a in the in this
in f5 right they have ribbon rule that
condition immediately can explain all
the original rules in the literature so
very quickly
okay let me see i'm around the time let
me go back to okay
i just want to comment that
we have a melon water the secret should
water you have many choices for secret
water so so here i just give a some of
them and you can see that uh
if i give different signature order the
running time will be very different okay
so you have a
uh
you you when you do imitation you have
to pick the one that's the best okay
okay just very quick maybe give me a
minute so uh some complex issues
so here uh one of things this little
example i only have one polynomial with
a quadratic quantum polynomial but other
just a simple polynomial also conjecture
of course and this problem is the number
of growth bases number elements in the
minimum growth is actually is
explanation
so so just write down the growth basis
actually is exponential in our case and
also if you talk about it in the same
same setting if i talk about the cubic
polynomial if you try to compute group
basis actually uh well
this will be very hard because the
counting the number solution of cubic
form is just sharp complete so this is
also hard part problem in this instance
and also there are bound uh related to
the complexity so because of how how how
much degree you can go so and uh i think
i'm i'm gonna well that's the bound and
there's a still ancient research on this
uh and there are many people i think in
audience work on this problem i think uh
so one of the things that uh this scene
for zero dimensional homogeneous idea
actually if you do randomization
change your variable actually you have
good bond on that one that's the
if you have a higher dimensional case
then the bond can be very bad
okay thank you
questions i have a question
can can you comment are some parts of
your algorithm uh or your methods uh
distributive can you like do many
computations at once that's a major
actual challenge for
in general for computer growth basis so
it's not very parallel yeah it's very
hot
do you anticipate any parts of what you
discussed being like
uh
you could uh re you could reduce at
least a promo i don't separate i don't
know the yeah i'm not sure exactly which
part you can how much you can do
so
any yeah questions
all right thank you